well into a seventh week in one of
Europe's strictest lockdowns just days
from a third deadline italians are
finally hearing what lies ahead
factories are to reopen from the 4th of
May
a week later retail shops and the week
after that bars restaurants and museums
book shops have been one of the very few
things allowed to reopen already but
it's made little difference economically
with people largely a very personal
tantal business economy knows Corsica
may see poor bargain re Santa's
attentive as gentleman Bert so quickly
you see some businesses have struggled
so much they simply won't reopen again
in regions like Veneto they're relaxing
a few measures sooner allowing people to
exercise more and have family gatherings
for the national holidays Veneto had a
similar early outbreak to its northern
neighbor Lombardi but tested far more
extensively and averted the same crisis
the government is looking to roll out
both tests for the virus and antibody
tests nationally as it looks
to loosen lockdown but this great
disparity from region to region for
instance three weeks ago health care
workers a greater exposure were
guaranteed test for cove at 19 but it's
up to local health authorities who's at
risk and how the tests are done so some
medics are paying for them privately we
visited a clinic in Lazio now offering
private antibody tests a quick blood
sample identifies who may have already
been exposed to Co bid 19 but the
majority of people paying for the tests
here are doctors
both injured nada I get a delay now you
ain't got enough but I don't follow for
a booty they're about to run out of
tests here orders for more or on hold
the scale of this pandemic means demand
for everything is the greatest challenge
italians seem to understand life can't
return to normal anytime soon but now at
least the endless horizon of lockdown is
slowly lifting sally Lockwood sky
newsroom